منذ سنوات ست سنوات تحديدا في 2016 انطلق
في عروض ستاند اب كوميدي كانت تجارب
محدوده وصغيره لكن كانت كافيه ليختبره
موهبته امام الجمهور وينتقل الى مرحله
اكبر وجمهور اوسع محمد اشرف مؤدي كوميدي
وصانع محتوى صنع قاعده من الجماهير خطوه
بخطوه وحاليا يشارك في حفلات وعروض
كوميديه مع منصات مختلفه على مسارح في
العديد من المحافظات المصريه هو ايضا كانت
سب اعلانات وشارك في كتابه البرنامج
الكوميدي الاجتماعي
للفنان احمد امين وكان احد اعضاء فريق
كتابه الجزء السادس من المسلسل الكبير قوي
يشارك ايضا في الموسم الذي يعرض في رمضان
المقبل وكتب حلقات في مسلسل نصفي الثاني
للفنان علي ربيع الجاري تصويره حاليا
بعدين في اسطمبات دائما معموله في السينما
محفوظه لازم تعمل في اي في اي فيلم زي
مثلا بيطلع لك واحد كذاب انت في الحياه
بتعرف الكذابه ازاي ممكن هو بيكلمك مثلا
يلا في الكلام يرمش يهرش يبص الناحيه
الثانيه يفكر بس عشان
بيخليها من كل ده
قلت له انت خرجت مع مريم امبارح تقول لك
مريم طبعا
لا طبعا
محمد نفسه وكيف يعرف نفسه
برامج
في بيت اهلي قوي وما بيعملش حاجات كثير
قوي في البيت وكده وفجاه اطلب منك ساعه
مش عارف انا حاجه مشكله اتحلت المشكله
الحمد لله بقيت باغسل بقيت باغسل المواعين
دلوقتي وبقيت تمام الحمد لله يعني
الصغيره ومحدوده بعدين انت شرته صار لك
جمهور واسع يعني حدثنا كيف حتى نجحت وصلك
هذا الجمهور العريض
الاول
كده الحفلات كانت صغيره وكنت بطلع اجره
قدام جمهور قليل بيبقى مثلا 30 او 40 واحد
وكان الاستاند الكوميدي في مصر عامه ما
كانش له شعبيه كبيره قوي لسه
فالموضوع كان صعب قوي في البدايه يعني بس
احنا كنا مكملين وفضلت اعمل حفلات
استمراريه يعني لحد 2019
2019 عملنا فرقه
احنا سبع كوميديانز انا وطه ووليد ومصطفى
عباس ومحمد حلمي احمد عصام من ساعتها
والحفلات بدات تكبر بدا جمهورنا يكبر لما
يعني لما اشتغلنا مع بعض على الموضوع
كفرقه الموضوع بقى يكبر اكتر واسرع والحمد
لله بقى في ناس كثير جدا دلوقتي في مصر
تعرف الاستاند الكوميدي كويس جدا عارفين
وكده يعني فالموضوع كده يعني
هلا مقطع لعبه الحبار شاركت فيه وهلا بس
هذا اللون مثل السكويت جيم قصدي ههه